das pony max auf einer weide in höchste
nordrhein-westfalen gerissen von einem
wolf wohl noch zwei weitere ponys
gerissen wurden innerhalb kurzer zeit
und übrig bleiben dann kadaver wie hier
wie groß ist die neue wolfs gefahr hier
in deutschland die rückkehr der wölfe
bei uns sprechen heute bei bild läuft
wie für die der wolf links gefährlich
geworden ist auf die weide auf das pony
max gerissen wurde schauen wir jetzt zu
unserem bild reporter michael engelberg
wann hat sich dass michael es uns jetzt
zugeschaltet schönen guten morgen alles
genau abgespielt
ja hallo patricia ich gehe mal ein
stückchen zur seite das hat ganze hat
sich am donnerstag abgespielt und zwar
in der nacht von mittwoch auf donnerstag
hier auf der weide und man sieht auf
diese weise sind jetzt keine keine tiere
mehr aber auf der anderen seite sind
jetzt noch zwei pferde
aufgestellt hintergrund ist dass die
besitzerin eigentlich am donnerstag
einen höheren zaun bauen wollte und hat
dann den maxi morgens vorgefunden man
geht davon aus dass es sich um das rudel
um welchen gloria handelt wölfin gloria
ist 2018 hier im bereich wesel
schermbeck hünxe er plötzlich
aufgetreten es gibt mittlerweile zwei
erwachsene tiere und mit jährlichen
nachkommen und hier ist die angst
natürlich groß normalerweise zuerst
wurden schafe angefallen und jetzt ponys
die wesentlich schwerer wesentlich
größer und wesentlich schneller sind und
natürlich haben die pferdebesitzer jetzt
hier rund um die weide angst weiß man
wie viele wölfe sich da in dieser
umgebung in rund um höchste
nordrhein-westfalen vielleicht insgesamt
aufhalten sollen kann man das schätzen
also es gibt grobe schätzung also hier
in dem bereich wie gesagt zwei
erwachsene tiere mit einem jährlichen
nachwuchs allerdings hat man uns am
sonntag als wir auf einem reiterhof der
sich ungefähr ja ich sag mal großen
kilometer von hier entfernt befindet
gesagt dass ein nachbar dieses hofes
beim letzten mal fünf wölfe auf einer
wild kamera gesehen hat und jetzt ist
natürlich die frage wie präparieren sich
die ganzen hofbesitzer präparieren sich
die ganzen reiterhöfe und wie stellen
sich die pferdebesitzer auf diese neue
gefahr ein normalerweise sind die
beiden hier eingezäunt und es ist strom
drauf aber wenn man mal so ehrlich ist
das sollte für den wolf wirklich kein
problem sein und ich muss auch sagen wir
stehen jetzt hier schon eine knappe
stunde in diesem gebiet und gucken uns
auch die ganze zeit um nicht weil wir
panik haben weil es schon auch ein
seltsames gefühl ist ja zu wissen dass
es hier wirklich richtig wilde tiere
gibt
michael engelberg vielen herzlichen dank
wir wollen hier weiter sprechen über den
wolf der zurück ist und welche gefahr er
in sich birgt welche gefahr für
landwirte welche gefahr aber auch für
waldspaziergänger und dazu sprechen wir
jetzt mit helmut dammann tamke es
präsident der landesjägerschaft
niedersachsen und vizepräsident des
deutschen jagdverbandes einen schönen
guten morgen
sagen sie wie groß ist die gefahr die
vom wolf ausgeht
so könnte menschen ist was
für die nutztiere wie in form von meiner
haltung auch die stadt sind ist die
gefahr
nicht zu unterschätzen
im jahr von den zehn jahre und 20 in
niedersachsen in niedersachsen weil über
240 nachgewiesenen übergriffen über 1000
nachgewiesene nutzer
über 1000 wölfe das heißt das sind vor
allen dingen
die tierhalter die sich sorgen machen
die angst haben davor dass es eben ihre
schafe erwischt ihre ponys service wie
wir gerade gesehen haben wie können die
sich jetzt schützen und sind sie der
auffassung dass man wölfe schießen
sollte
die wölfe die nächsten in euro person in
deutschland die feste schon zu
kategorien die unter naturschutz recht
kennt von gaga eine einfache antwort im
sinne von wölfe abschließen wie jetzt
rechtlich im moment gar nicht gegeben
deshalb haben
landwirte nutzte
schäfer die ihre tiere draußen auf der
weide halten im moment nur eine chance
über entsprechenden zaunbau ihre tiere
zu schützen die erfahrung lehrt
allerdings dass auch bei diesen zaunbau
über die jahre eine gewisse
aufrüstung stattfindet also der
grundschutz begann man mit 90 zentimeter
umzäunen wurde dann schnell auf 21
erhöhen und es gibt auch us-territorium
wo mittlerweile eine zahlung in höhe von
140 von den wölfen übungen ja der zaun
ist das eigentlich fragte nur ja nach
den gesetzen jetzt haben sie die achsel
aktuelle gesetzeslage noch mal wieder
gegeben das könnte man ja aber
möglicherweise auch ändern werden sie
dafür dass es dahingehend geändert wird
dass man eben will verschießen darf
also wir haben in deutschland die
aktuellen zahlen wenn dieser tage wieder
veröffentlicht aber ich gehe davon aus
dass wir davon ausgehen können dass in
deutschland mittlerweile 150
nachgewiesen haben in nordrhein
westfalen wie sie im bewaffnet haben
haben wir offensichtlich
ist
steht überhaupt nicht zur debatte in den
bundesländern brand durch sachsen-anhalt
mecklenburg-vorpommern und niedersachsen
wo wir mittlerweile eine etablierte
problem zum haben gibt es durchaus die
verbandspolitischen forderung über einen
bestandsmanagement das schnelle und auch
exponentielle wachstum der population
einzugrenzen
beim tanken herzlichen dank für diese
informationen und wir schauen jetzt
quasi direkt zum wolf schauen uns das
einmal genauer an ihnen noch einen
schönen tag denn im wildpark johannes
mühle vor einem wolfsgehege da ist jetzt
unser bild reporter hans raab tragik
entschuldige und hannes ist quasi direkt
vor dem wolf
wie ist das wie fühlt sich das ich hoffe
du kannst du dich an dort die wölfe in
diesem wildpark sowie man die eigentlich
gerne hat also schön zum ansehen aber
auch schön mit abstand und in sicherheit
also da würden sich die ponys pony max
würde sich über diesen anblick mehr
freuen
also hier im wildpark johannes mühle
fühle ich mich rundum sicher hier ist
auch ein über zwei meter hoher zaun noch
mit drei
elektrokabeln die gespannt worden sind
um die wölfe ebenda zu halten wo sie
hingehören direkt nebenan ist damwild
muffelwild da ist eben es notwendig dass
du wirklich ein sicherer zaun eine
sichere barriere die wölfe und das
schalenwild trend von daher fühle ich
mich extrem sicher unsicherer fühlen
sich aber menschen die ich im laufe
meiner reporter tätigkeit in den letzten
jahren immer wieder auch getroffen habe
schafhalter zum beispiel bin befreundet
auch mit einem schäfer in der nähe von
grünheide da wo tesla jetzt baut der mir
erzählt hat es ist unheimlich
problematisch für ihn er hat eine kleine
herde mit mit wechsel weidehaltung jedes
mal wenn die schafe umziehen neue
elektrozäune aufzubauen und jeden tag
ein zwei mal eben um die gesamte koppel
rumzulaufen und zu gucken ob da
vielleicht ein ast auf den elektrozaun
gefallen ist um eben diese barriere dann
bat geschwind wolf auch überwindbar zu
machen und die schafe eben auch nicht
mehr zu schützen ich glaube es ist ein
große diskrepanz die in den jahren
festgestellt habe zwischen städtern und
zwischen der landbevölkerung in berlin
und in münchen sieht ein wolf so aus das
ist ein wolf den ich als kind noch zum
spielen bekommen habe der ist niedlich
der ist putzig da freut man sich wenn
der wolf die artenvielfalt in
deutschland wieder bereichert die leute
auf dem land die wissen aber dass der
wolf so eben nicht aussieht sondern das
ist wirklich ein gefährliches raubtier
ist der großen hunger hat und der eben
nicht unterscheidet zwischen rehwild und
zwischen schafen und letzten endes
wollen wir ja eine landwirtschaft die
auf den feldern funktioniert wo die
tiere in der freiheit leben und das ist
eben wirklich nur bedingt möglich und
bedingt auch eine wirtschaftlich möglich
wenn der wolf in hohen stückzahlen in
dieser gegend eben auch heimisch ist und
wenn man dann sagt ihr müsst höhere
zäune bauen ihr müsst mehr elektro
anbringen oder müsste herdenschutzhunden
bauen verkaufen das ist wirtschaftlich
eben extrem schwierig einen hund kostet
ungefähr 10.000 euro und wenn man jetzt
sagt man hat nur 1 23 scharf
zwei drei kleine herden dann geht das
schnell wirklich in die hunderttausende
und das ist wiederum auch nicht möglich
wenn das im naherholungsgebiet ist die
schäfer sagen wie soll ich denn hier
einen scharfen hund an die an die herde
stellen wenn wir den wolf vertreibt dann
vertrag der auch die spaziergänger das
ist also eine unheimlich schwieriges
thema und ich glaube oder das was ich
gehört habe ist dass die landwirte auf
jeden fall sagen wir haben in
deutschland mittlerweile viel zu viele
wilde lebende wölfe die schätzung gehen
ja von 1000 bis hin zu 5000 stück man
weiß es eben nicht weil längst nicht
alle tiere geschützt sind von daher ist
die dunkel zahl sehr groß und ich denke
dass der gesetzgeber den möglichst
schnell vor allem am besten noch in
dieser legislaturperiode neue
gesetzliche grundlagen schaffen muss
damit eventuell leben jäger auch
eingreifen in die population natürlich
im rahmen einer stabilen populationen
dass der wolf eben nicht wieder
ausgerottet wird in deutschland und das
ist eine stabile und gesunde population
gibt aber eben die landwirte die so
wirtschaften wie wir es wollen mit
glücklichen tieren die frei auf den
weiden sich bewegen dürfen dass die auch
eine chance haben weiter überleben zu
können also ganz klare forderung vom
land wie du sagst von den landwirten von
den schäfern an die politik sich endlich
um den wolf zu kümmern beziehungsweise
um sie zu kümmern und darum dass man
sich vor dem wolf eben besser schützen
kann wo ist er denn aktuell hannes der
wolf und wenn man ihn hinter dir gerade
nicht sieht weil er sich irgendwo da im
unterholz versteckt wo ist ja im moment
am meisten in deutschland der wolf
krey wolf ist im oberen drittel mmm mmm
im süden des des oberen drittels
praktisch und zieht sich von der oder
bis an die an die westgrenze da sind die
großen population schwerpunkte im süden
und ganz oben im norden ist ja eher
selten zu sehen und aber er breitet sich
aus der wolf weiß auch dass zur zeit
eben von menschen keine gefahr ausgeht
ich habe in norwegen samen gesehen das
ist praktisch diese um bevölkerung dar
da hat jeder sagen die haben eben große
rentierherden die frei auch da oben
leben da hat jeder seine neben sich auf
dem beifahrersitz ein gewehr liegen und
wenn er durch die landschaft werde ein
wolf sieht dann hält er kurz an macht
die scheibe runter und schießt den tod
und sagt es ist doch mehr egal irgendwie
ob der geschützt ist oder nicht ich habe
mir seit tausenden von jahren haben wir
rentiere gehalten und eben auch wölfe
gejagt und das machen wir nach wie vor
weiter so der population in norwegen
zumindest hat das nicht geschadet
denn auch hinter dir wirklich
wunderschöne tiere haben es aber dennoch
möchte ich ihnen beim waldspaziergang
nicht begegnen daher ganz kurz was mache
ich im seltenen fall wenn ich ein wolf
sehr wie verhalte ich mich
also die situation ist ja meistens dass
man entweder in den pilzen ist oder mit
dem hund spazieren geht oder mit mit der
familie unterwegs ist wenn man dann
tatsächlich was zum glück immer noch
selten vorkommt weil die wölfe in der
regel immer doch noch sehr scheu sind
aber man sollte man eben in die
situation kommen dass man ein wolf
sichtet und er ist mehr als 50 meter weg
dann ist die empfehlung macht auf euch
aufmerksam
also vielleicht wenn man alleine ist
sollte man laut singen ein wanderlied
vielleicht wenn man sie noch auf den
lippen hat oder in die hände klatschen
oder einfach so geräusche machen dass
der wolf von uns nicht erschreckt wird
sondern dass er weiter hinten sind
spaziergänger wunderbar und dann ruhig
und langsam die richtung wechseln in die
entgegengesetzte richtung zum wolf
laufen sich einfach trollen praktisch
und den wolf und ruhe lassen wenn der
wolf jetzt direkt vor einem stehen
sollte was gottlob sehr sehr selten und
sehr unwahrscheinlich ist dann sollte
man und auch rückwärts gehen man sollte
den wolf trotz im auge behalten man
sollte rückwärts sich entfernt von dem
wolf wenn der wolf wider erwarten
angreift dann ist es so wie wenn ein
hund angreift dann sollte man den kopf
schützen versuchen hals und kopf zu
schützen weil das die positionen sind
die am gefährlichsten sind die am
verwundbarsten sind und geschützt mit
kopf und hals rückwärts gehen und
versuchen sich in sicherheit zu bringen
da lassen wir uns ja niemanden vom
experten bekommt wenn man eben wirklich
ein wolf hat vor sich hat und das muss
man dann eben beherzigen wegrennen wäre
das schlimmste was man machen kann